喂喂
然后
听到
你有去我们新的网站吗
上次那个吗
对
或者你投屏
可以
你投屏
然后打开那个文
然后再打开我们的新网站
好的
是之前你不是登录进去过
对吧
对
他的他都是在右半边
不是有一个他的右半边有一个购物车
我记得
然后产品中心
你点到产品中心
对
对然后我们希望的是在产品中心这里也有一个购物车的这个
就是这个产品中心这里边你再往下列这些都就机器人相关这些东西我们都会明码标价
但是我们不想放在主页里面
可能会是像苹果那种小后端去评估的话
去苹果这里
也就是说他这里比如说对他这里其实是产品介绍
对吧
这里也是产品
对然后你去选那个选购点
那个选购
对他选购了以后
他才会跳到他具体的
因为这里才会有具体的型号以及这些配置什么的
他这个斜杠和shop应该是单独另外一个网站里面的对
所以我们也是想着在首页这里网页网站上做一个
这样的OK对
所以你可以刚刚说是放什么来着
也是你说商城里面
你说商场里面就是放我们的产品的
就是你去我们首页那里看
什么零条轴
夹杂机械臂的那些东西
但是这里有一个问题
就是我们在想
就是可能你看看有没有好的这种后台管理
要不然以后维护的话可能是个麻烦的事情
你说其实他首先我们现在首先确认的是一个账号体系了
对
你看现在这里是没有账号登录的对
所以你要综合考虑一下
这里首先有账号
有购物车
然后有有这些
只是说最后变成我们的这个变成我们最后怎么把购物车嵌到我们的OS里面
对吧
然后OS里面是有设备库
OS现在
不是上次做的那个设备库那里吗
对
从那设备库那里添加进去
也就是说他其实是一个先他
相当于在设备库里做设计
做完了以后他他那边对
然后他那边就应该能出现那个购物车了
然后一键下单
对不对
对对对你看其实这个环节也很重要
就是他他这里提供了一个这个叫什么death for是吧
这个叫然后
有
这个项目
对
然后有这个设计
有订单
对
他他他他是他是这个逻辑
我们好像缺少一个这个地方
比如说我们我们这个里面的那个那那现在的那一套的话
应该像是他design或者是project里面的详情
对
其实我们现在也有一个后台
到时候你可以找陆风看一下
我们其实现在也做了一个管理后台的
但是让管理后台更偏向工程师
更偏向管理员
他不像不偏向用户
所以你看一下
就是我们其实对我们我们的平台入口其实是有一个
机房进去的那那先梳理一下
就是一个一个我们的一个客户
他可能会分几种角色
比如说分这个会会因为他有可能会加设备
我觉得采购可能倒不用在这里
哦哦哦工程师那你除了工程师
还有还有
还有他的管理员
管理员是跟沟通就是
可以区别
就是他可以管理这个团队的模型库
设备库
它可以添加
可以修改
对
其实也是工程师
可能就是一个负责人这个样子就是开一部分权限给他了
对不对
开心
是是是开一部分权限
这个逻辑对不对
对对对
开一部分权限
你这里面对
对对对
这种
对的
他这个型材
对
现在线上的那个做的怎么样了
我看一下
要稍等
我本来喂
听得到吗
听得到
听到现在就是
按照你之前设计的那个图纸
你说是那个设备库是吗
对
我我我看在我们这应该是接在哪里
上次那个设备库那里
我这个后台好像看不到设备库
这个是网页端
这个是我们这是top图的
这个跟我们3D这边是没有太大关系
这个没有仿真的是吧
要不然我这边采集一下
对但是我觉得是这样
等等会儿
等会儿你说这个里边它其实也是要有那个入口的
我所以我让那个谁拉上来了
上线了
那个陆丰应该也上线了
就是现在的那个就是现在的这个设备库里边
其实也是需要添加这个购物车功能
现你说现在设备库是这个设备库吗
这里设备库对
他不是上面是他已经添加进来的
对吧
这个上半部分好上来
对对对
也是头上
所以这里应该也要让它出现一个
比如说从哪里弹出一个地方
让他你是看一下用弹窗
用什么方式
反正就是也得能看到它的这个就像购物车这样的功能
对吧
因为这些是已经开始了的
对你选的话
才会有3D那边就出现两个重复的
不是
他这边是只进购物车
不是看我们3D的那个
对
他我就需要有一个进三就那个购物车的一个
对我觉得不那边还需要生成一个购物车吗
也要
也一样的
不冲突
我觉得不冲突
也就是从这边
同一个区也会有的
对
应该是同一个购物车
是同一个购物车
假设他没有3D的那个软件的话
他不是应该也能在这里去搭建去投
然后去下单
两边都要是吧
两边都要
然后两边是共通的数据
它是同一个数据源
就是同一个购物车
可以联合理解
对
那这个我创建一下他的购物车是不是
然后是不是按项目分的
然后陆风把把我们那些管理后台打开
给设计师看一下
那行
我让罗红把现在那个管理后台
他其实也是从那个地方入进去的
你刚才不是打开了我们那个网页
那个那个对
不是是OS的
那个对
然后右上角它不是也有那个吗
不是网页端的
右上角
的那我们那个图像对
他的是右上角的哪个
是不是不是对
这个后台管理
对对对
我看一下之前我有没有这个面对
我的想法
对是一样的
然后我的意思是就是你看一下是从这里去去到那种的
还是说另外敲
就是用那种右上角一个
比如说这个三角加一个购物车这样的形式
就是在右上角的那个图标那里
比如说加一个
我觉得应该两个都要了
按他这个逻辑应该是两个都要
就是我这个是工程里面
这个是安排接下的项目
然后我加了很多东西我去创建
然后你刚刚那个后台是不是有点像这个对当
我
创建一个订单的时候
都没创建我
没见
我操要填写这么多东西
这个还是在细节上面
我没有想好这个怎么去算的价格
这个要提示了
对
就是这个下不了
我估计是下完了之后
这个肯定也是一个列表
就跟这个设计一样的
然后他有他的这个项目
他刚刚解决订单
那我感觉是不是应该是他把所有设备都拖完之后
然后我们有一个比如说叫什么生成生成那个订单的一个功能
然后才给他把这些信息给生成出来
对
从订单的功能就是因为他他如果
不点的话
我们也没必要说他拖一个模型
我们就给他那个算一下
首先这个其实是一个可选的步骤是吧
其实他是他搭建方案的时候
我们是不确定他有没有这些物料
他其实是可能有的
对不对
对所以
其实也就是说他这整个方案里面的话
就是搭建的这个物料
他可以可能可以会下单购买
相当于这里这个物料清单
这个不就是物料清单
我们我们我们除了网页版以外的话
是仿仿那个那个桌面版
那个仿真跟这边只有两个这样的列表
对不对
对的是重复的那应该就提到全局来
就是放一个购物车在全局这里
对我觉得是这购物车在全局会好的对吧
包括我们网站入口
其实我们那个官网的那里
其实应该也有一个购物车的全局的这个
那如果全局的话
数据用哪边的呢
其实全局你这一边是有一个项目语境在的
就是这个打开了当前项目
就肯定是他他会出现一个情况
就是你在top图这边可能拖了一些硬件
但在3D那边有可能模型跟这边硬件可能不是不一定能全部匹配的上的
我们只是给他一个清单
你是可以把它最最全的这个列列出来
你比如说我在3D3D的场景里面
我可能需要拖一张桌子出来
对吧
但其实你在投的设备这边是不需要桌子的
对对对
但是我们也不卖桌子的
对不对
我是目前立足
目前是这样的
但是我们还是瞄首先现在聚焦还是聚焦在我们自己设备库的这个设备里面
核心是这个如果是客户用确实需要加工
或者是说什么型材类的
我们这个可以放在第二步再去做
但是这个的话肯定不在做不足的
那这个的话我觉得是这样用一个颜色区分
比如说购物车里边
它的这个里边一部分是我们这种就是相当于分成两个
一个叫做什么加工件
你可以叫做一个叫做这个叫什么
就是一个叫加工件
一个叫这种叫叫什么
就是标标准件或者叫标准件
这个或者说叫叫这个会对设备
对分两块来给他们
因为我们现在实际下单不也是这样下的吗
我们现在一种是标准的
一种是定制的
对不对
对
就像刚才说什么桌子什么的
其实全部都是叫做型材类什么
那就全部按照那个全部当成这种叫做
定制件收货这样子对不对
然后给他分个类
对
是的
之前这
两天
我觉得全部列出来
他哪怕不要或者是我们不卖
但是这个清单
是有完整的对
有个完整清单给他
然后他到时候下不下单
他自己去勾选的
他要不要这些东西
他就是勾
对就是说勾选我们就只提供我们有的卖的给他勾选
对对对
然后他任何时候打开这个订单的时候
他可以去下载
就是完整的看到我们有卖的卖给他的这个进度怎么样的
然后完整的怎么样的对对
是的
我就那我觉得像在这样的
逻辑就比较清晰了
对
就比较清晰了
对就是做一个全局的
然后把把top图里面跟仿真里面的都放过去
然后给一个清单
对
然后他如果当他去点击的时候
这个是check out是购物车对不对
这个下单流程了
这个下单流程其实就可以放到刚刚的这个来去做了
理论上它应该是属于这里的一部分了
但是用户是进不到这个界面的
这不是我们的目前现在用户是进不到的
所以就是说看看是不是
所以是不是在右上角
比如说在刚才那个那个界面
对这里的右上角再加一个
就是右上角这里再加个图标变成购物车
或者是再变成一个什么样的
对
刚刚说在这边加个图标
他点下单的时候相当于给我们服务器发个消息
然后我们能知道
对
我我我刚刚想提的是这里加上购物车
但已经达成共识了
然后点了之后
它它肯定有一个购物车的步骤
就是确认清单
选择付款方式
填写收货地址
然后点击然后去一个收银台是吧
那怎么付款之类的对对
那些是另外一个区域了
我觉得另外做一个界面
我是说这一整套界面应该是归属于另外一个地方
我们是说归属在我刚刚想说归属在官网上
还是说归属在这个管理后台呢
你们刚刚说的意思是这个其实
觉得只有我觉得对这我觉得不做在这个管理后台
我觉得还是做在官网
而且现在是这样的
我们接下来可能会考虑一种模式
就是我们会在官网上面放一个不涉及账户
就是纯体验的一个这个就是刚才你的黑OS的那个网页
本体对
等会儿就是左边再走第就是OS的那个OS那个标签
对我们可能会放一个这个
然后做一个类似刚才那个version的那种
比如说拿three CJS做一个简版的
也就是说在这个上面他不能相当于给别人可以在这里拖拖拽拽
然后就直接体验一下的这种东西
我们在考虑这个方式
对就是这个
假项目吗
是个假项目
对是个假项目
对就纯粹为了给他们
反正而且他退出以后
这个信息数据就没了
这个使用场景是什么
就是介绍我们这个系统
对
就介绍这个系统
然后你说放在这里的是个什么
是个是个帮忙
不对我觉得这个事情是不是可以这样做
就是说你首先你这个体验
你这个体验版或者体验的账号
你是想这个入口是想放在哪里的
这是什么什么场景下会让因为
现在很多人现在很多是用户
他其实是不能直接看到我们这个系统的
所以他是个什么场景
是这些用户他绝对是网上
其实对其实我觉得我的思路是这样的
你你你去看过绿绿联的那个那个吗
OS绿绿联绿联的手机配件
那个绿联吗
对你去绿联的那是你去打开他的网页
绿联的纳斯
绿联纳斯
对绿联纳斯它有个它首页上面有个体验
点开官网
对然后他有一个体验
他那个体验是会给你一个账号密码的
你可以登进去看到他所有的功能
不在这里
对OS这就在系统软件
就刚才你那个系统软件在线体验
对我们想法是做一个这样的
然后点进去之后对
然后再到那个体验界面
对对对
你可以现在直接点他
很快的就输个号码
他就直接那个了
对你可以看到他体验它实际上不是一个真的它不是一个真的运行环境
他是一个纯虚拟的
有有我之前群辉好像也做过这种事情
对
我们想法是把我们的OS做一个这样的
在官网上面做一个这样的入口
这样的话用户他就能至少直观的知道我们这个系统长什么样
反正他他就是个假的
对吧
但是它里边还是有些数据的
就是相当于是一些假数据
对
我们说过要这么
要对
所以你一起把这个设计了
相当于你看看把我们现在包括3D那边
比如说现在比如说unit那个他是不是可以直接导一个web
张军他我们那个现在可以直接导简版的外部可以做吗
就比如说打一个能力
但对就是打可能没适配
对
但我们这边现在适配的只有windows和linux
那个外部DR的可能要看一下
对我觉得我们不要求全功能
我们只需要这个理解我的意思
其实是一个简版的
这个对不对
这就是
大致是做一个
比如说让他们把模型拖拽到场景里面
然后比如说看看对
看看然后能能能比如说拖个GCP
拖个一两个东西
或者说我们里面已经构建了一个最小系统
比如说就是一些必须要夹板架带什么东西
这样他们就可以在这里边拖拽
然后再编下层
然后设备库他也不能
他只能看
他不能拖很多东西
就大部分东西都不能拖的对
就是这种
你看他现在这个也是这样的
绿点这个他也是这样的
你看他他他点开他就是这个状态
他其实你是看不到他这些
他就是一步步引导而已
对其实我们现在也陆丰这边其实也做了一些引导
就相当于我们进去这个地方
就让他来一步步引导
然后这里面其实你是点不了的
你也下载不了
你也不能那个
对他这些都是不能看
就是不能那个的对对
就现在有一些已经有一些数据了
但是你是你既不能往里边上传
你也不能往里边
他这个是既不能往里面上传
也不能什么对吧
就是类似这样的东西
就是说相当于把我们的OS放一个到这个官网上
要不然现在你看哪一个客户就是搞试用
他其实也感受不到这个东西
对吧
我觉得像那个引流的这个作用
你做
一个对
现在这个版本就是
这个优先级没有这么高
但是我们希望还是在你们这一版
比如说这一版本的迭代接近一个状态里头
就是弄一个最小化的对
但是我这边要做的是只是放了一个入口在官网上
对不对
然后你还稍微设计一下下
看看用什么布局界面
就是嵌在一起的时候
你里面肯定我觉得最好是不要改
我听起来应该不应该做任何改
就是说这里就是一个体验账号而已
其他都是
尽可能的仿真
对而且这里都不应该有任何的区别
应该是一样的
就是在你哪里介绍这个系统的上
是是虽然是一样的
但是也有个问题
就是可能我们不想把那个底
比如说像那种什么后台管理什么的就不放出去了
就可能要缩减一些东西
这可能右上角好这些就没有那么多功能了
有一些可能就
去掉这个
就做一个就是
做一个
disable的状态给他
就是看到他有这个功能
但是这点不进去的就行了
我觉得
这样也行
可以
对还是尽可能保持一致
你本来就是想让他体验一下有什么吗
对这个主要是定一下边界
我感觉这里不需要设计是什么
要设计的是我是这么理解的
要设计的肯定是说这里有一个OS的一个介绍的
然后一样也是给他一个体验账号
填了之后也是到达这么一个界面
告诉他我这个体验的账号是什么
他自己去登录进去
看到这些一切的东西一样的
是不是这样
对吧
是是是
这样的
我们说回这个是另外一个需求
我们说回刚刚说的那个购物车的需求
购物车的话就是我们我​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌刚刚说到这里有一个车图标
点进去了之后是一个关于这个项目他在拓图跟仿真这边所有的这些设备的一个平台
对吧
他一点击相当于就跳走了
跟这个一样的
就点击的话
它就进入了一个check out的这个过程了
这个下单过程里面就是首先确认他有哪些东西
然后他去选择要去下单购买的东西
再下一步的话就是填写地址
那个结款的方式
应该有些什么对公之类的这种
对吧
对公付款的这种发票的填写之类的这这这些应该要管理的
然后再对再完成下单
完成下单了之后
首先这一系列的页面
刚刚说的就是说它应该是属于官网的
对不对
也就是说拿我们这个我们这个页面对应它的话
那它的逻辑上应该就是说我们这里也应该有一个商城是这样的
然后商城右上角这里至少也要加一个个人中心跟购物车
​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌对吧
然后我其实有个想法
就是他这个账号允不允许他
比如说像你去看一下佳丽创总
他比如说创建企业账号
因为我们可能会对公
然后底下工程师可能他自己的账号这种方式要不要建这种层级
因为你看交易上它其实是有个公司账号
然后他可以给公司账号开采购开就是给采购开个账号
再给工程师开个账号
现在工程师只管下单
他只管添加购物车
然后采购就会去那个里面去做结算
他强力窗是这样做的
对
行那我得体验一下力创的那个对交易商
是那样做的
交易仓他不是打3D打印
什么PCP什么那些
我知道你们有钱交易商的账号吗
我没有
但是我们是公司用
这可能不方便给你
不是给我就截个图给我看一下
有数据的那个
我可以让工程师到时候截个图给你
对对对
有我去创的话
肯定是个非常空白的账号
行
然后我们这个商城在官网上面的话
它也是有一些分类
对不对
这个也是按照按照我们这个OS这个系统里面的这些产品的分类
其实就是这个是不是对
然后他也是可以在这里面去查看每一个详情
然后加入购物车
然后在购物车里面去下单
是的那这些字段的什么的
是不是暂时也先沿用选的这这一套可以
可以先把它做出来
你们再提一下
如果有什么不一样的
对对对
再弄
对再改
对是你先弄呗
就是我的意思是至少你今天有100
完了我们可以先在上上面
因为我们官网新的马上要上线了
所以我想的是如果可以的话
就把这个功能
你这个不是已经上线了吗
我们有新的就是里面的子页面还在迭代
对
OK好的
对我想的就是说这样的话
我们那就相当于叫什么
就是我们至少可以把把这个那一页的地方
把这个给它关联起来
因为我们现在商城这块还没有
产品里面还不完善
现在你先看到的官网产品这块不完善
行
这个需求我大概了解了
然后个人中心那里面要做什么
也是订单
目前还有刚才说的那个不同人的这个权限的管理
然后那个什么对
其实就是至少让他整个的购物车看起来是所有的是应该就是同一套
同一套数据库
行
对
然后我的意思是你回头可能
陆峰我想跟你说
之前不是让你看那个管理商城后台的吗
就这一块你觉得是这怎么弄比较好
因为这个会跟这里直接对
就是因为后期我们比如说自己家产品再去这个
你是说发到时候我们做一个这个商城
然后再配一个后台给他发布这个产品
对不对
对
肯定就不是我们工程师自己干了
这个肯定我交给什么产品部或者市场部他们去去搞
对
就这个呃然后然后是我这边要把这个后台设计一下
还有什么
对
就是看看怎么弄
你这个有什么建议
你方有什么建议
我现在搭了一个后基础的后台
就是页面
给他看一下
可以给先给设计师看一下
我能打开吗
没在我现在共享一下
你可能打不开
但是你可能要给共享
行行行
它就是一个这样的页面
就是一些基础
的功能这里是
商品的分类
然后商品的列表
然后就编辑那些价格什么之类的
然后详情就可以编辑它那种详情页放很多图片的那种
你这个里面的这个字段什么的是确定了吗
我只是大概写了一下
就我认为有一些的
哦哦哦那你这个我能打开吗
目前我
等会在部署一下
在1．40上
我觉得这个已经你看订单管理
产品管理
商品的管理
这些都已经有了
但是只是现在很粗略
就是有一些细节我不确定要怎么做
就比如说详情里面发货什么之类的
还有各种东西
退款什么之类的
这些不够明确
其实我们这个是不是可以专门找一个现成的系统来去做
因为这种东西没必要
我原来也是这个想法
所以我说看看你们对一下
有我前面给乐风看了几个
他说觉得不太合适
因为他那些感觉也是个半成品
你也就一两周的工作量
这个可能找的那些模板都是差不多的
行
但是你用别人的架构
你可能到时候改起来就会不是很被框死
不是很好改
行那其实我不用太关注这个
我们先把刚刚前面的部分先定下来
就是前面决定怎么样去展示这个
到时候这个字段看前面大家都是比较能够直观感知到的
然后再去调整这个后台了
你觉得这样子就你觉得
就这样子可以
就两种方式
一种的话就是如果我们现在已经有很明确的说
我们这些商品大概有哪些字段
然后订单怎么管理
其实都是可以参考别的这个成熟的后台的
那现在参考跟之后参考也差不多
我们现在就是重点关注在在我们的那个官网上面
这些东西应该怎么展示出来
但是我们官网是准备做那种强制登录吗
如果没有强制登录
他就没办法
购物车不是强制登录
不是就跟苹果一样
对你得下单之后才要求你登录
他可以查看商品
然后点击购买的时候
这个时候要求登录是吗
最后结算时候
我记得苹果是你可以选选
选完了
最后他只有那个什么状态下才才用
那你加购物车涉及到
我觉得应该是加购物车的时候就应该
对对对
就是加购物车
我记得苹果是加购物车
对对对
你加购物车的时候
我们涉及到下次你打开购物车还能看到你之前加购的一些方案
对不对
对
行
那我觉得先这个我先不用管它
就是把前台这块做好了之后
看接下来还有什么困难要设计的地方
我到时候再参与
那就这么多了
对
然后你这一块需求就这么多
然后你跟张建他们对一下
上次剩余的一点呗
在对
那上次那个我是看不到
我现在是上次给的那个网页给我也是刚刚那个问题
你那是看看不到哪个来
你那是看不到哪个来着
那仿真仿真
仿真是因为你只能投屏
上次我们聊那个事情是我们要编排他的这个演示的版本
对吧
他的一些动作之类的
是在真正的这个程序里面是没有的吗
然后夹取各个物品
还有各种传感器的状态
那就看一下之前版本的那个是吧
对我现在是没有什么概念
这个东西到底要怎么做
我先投屏看一下
下载一下这个
上次是说夹物料的那个
对吧
对
然后我看之前好像是
之前好像是你比如说这个机器人要去夹这个杯子
对吧
对然后他是在这边要去添加一条这种什么叫什么补充行为的
然后这里面去编辑
他这里面有什么判断条件
判断技巧
到达了之后
然后下面又有这个
比如从这边去输
要去讲哪个物料的名称
就这一套有可能用户用起来
其实丢给用户的话
他其实也不太会用这个东西
然后维持我们如果做新的话
就说在仿真的时候
让这个机器人去夹这个物料的时候
它让它变成一个自动的行为
就比如说我这个夹爪到这个杯子这边
然后夹爪闭合
它闭合完之后我就能自动的去把这个杯子给夹住
那这个条件的话是自动的判断
按理说你比如说我这夹角到杯子这个位置了
然后他又执行了夹爪闭合这个动作
那他就应该自动触发那个夹爪
自动触发夹取那个功能
对吧
按理说是只需要检测到它有没有物料的
引擎这边是能检测到他那个家具范围内是否有物料的
按照我们之前的理解
应该就是只用编写这个机器人到对应的位置
然后执行夹取
然后由用力体内部的自身的那个碰撞系统去检测是否有物料
如果有物料就直接夹取到了
然后我们就直接后续的流程就直接走了
不需要去配置这一系列的这种
比如说专门定义一个假取的一个行为
按理说这个逻辑就是那个地方有物料我们就是假取到
那个地方没有物料我们就假取不到
是这样的
所以在这个配置的这个过程当中
是先要把仿真上把这个设备摆到那个夹的那个位置
对不对
才能够检测到那个杯子
对
这个应该是有一个捕捉的功能的
就是你在鼠标在场景里面选
然后他用实验检测去检测到对应的点位
然后他那个机械臂就能生成一个对应点位的一个姿态
他如果是转移动这个夹子到那个杯子
他对的不是那么准的
就是他他坐他坐标上
可能比如说他他已经跟这个是有碰撞的
我差一点点
你如果说不是偏差特别大的话是可以的
比如说你不可能说肉眼看起来就偏很大
那那他肯定就不行
这种我问的就是这种细节上
用户还有需要去调的必要吗
比如说我边我夹
这个然后它有个夹取范围
所以按照我们之前想法是你比如说他这个夹爪
它一定会有一个识别的范围
对吧
然后可以让用户自己去配这个它识别的范围是多大
那你夹的位置也是要用户自己去配吗
对
我们可以给他初始设置
我们会在同一个初始
设置一个比较对对对
大概比较正常的
每每一种应该是我们初始对每一种设备它是加什么位置
要有一个配置
比如说这个爪子
这个爪子放到这个杯子那里
反正只要放到他那个附近
那就可以去有这个选项
说要夹起这个杯子
当我们配置了这个选项了之后
它一定是个标准的夹取杯子的动作
这个能做到吗
就是夹子夹杯子
它一定是夹杯子的哪个地方
比如说腰部的某个位置
这是事先预知的
其实我们是会在这个杯子
你比如说这个杯子它这整一个形状
对吧
对我们会在它这个形状上加一层
那个叫clear
然后他他如果说像这个
我们会在夹角的两端也会加那个做一个是加那个叫什么碰​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌撞体
假如说他那个范围跟杯子的范围检测到了
那它就可以夹取到了
你想要两个盒子有接触的话
两个盒子有接触的话
他们就是能产生碰撞
我们知道这个碰撞信息
我们就知道现在是能夹到的
我们有会执行这个夹取的这个任务
是理论上来说是不需要去配置的
因为那个碰撞体体碰撞体是需要配的
但是我们会预制一个
然后用户如果觉得这个碰撞体有问题的话
后续也会开放编辑
他自己去编辑这个碰撞体到底有多大
现如今这个补充行为这个界面是指的是哪个编辑
就是编辑这些抓取
对
比如说你刚刚说的那个
如果他觉得不合适的情况下
是现在的哪一个编辑
不合适的情况下
你说是编辑那个碰撞体的大小是吗
对
或者是位置什么的
那个正常来说是有一个可视化的
就是我们会把那个碰撞体在场景那以一个盒子的形式去显示出来
然后再你去拖拽那个盒子的
那个是只有
六个方向
九个方向
那个可以大概给你看一下他那个
现在这边应该是有一个应该类似一个小例子
你怎么卡住了呢
我这个机器人默然不是有那个杯子吗
​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌对
然后他是在